[Music]
the errant Fox has stopped underneath
the basket
[Applause]
here's Curry's three to all warriors ten
of 13 they've made eight straight make
that nine straight but the Kings are you
know staying right with him just to
Edward Allah
oh how 31:22 how does he get opened
round 42:29 make that 42 to 29 Kevin
Orissa three they were behind the line
and that will do it for the first eight
Oh run for Golden State
eleven Oh run for Golden State Durant
freeing up cauley-stein knocked it away
into the hands of pogon of itch five
point game box to the red-hot buddy
hield
29 for buddy hield and the Kings have
the largest lead stolen it comes poke
out of its members buddy
he stops oh boy oh he's gotta get a
better shot than that yes he does the
Kings there's a hole for the time
because that's what happens with you and
you don't get yourself a quality one
they'll come back down and
[Applause]
[Music]
luli
three more on the way Sixpoint game
twelve Oh run curry defender falls down
and that makes it 1 2001 19 we are under
three minutes here in the fourth quarter